let's bring in Scott Van Pelt by the way
great work all week long on Wednesday
night you guys did some really great
stuff there during that Dallas game you
guys on your show did a wonderful job
thanks for joining us Scotty it's my
pleasure and and Dan as someone that
truly could understand it when you go up
to do a Phil segment of Phil being just
as it's advertised in between games
following the Dallas game in
anticipation of the New Orleans
Sacramento game and then you find that
that game is canceled and then you're
feel sick it becomes an hour and
something of live entirely unscripted no
commercial break television it is it's
something it's memorable that's for sure
and obviously the content wasn't what
any of us wanted but we were just trying
to give the you know most updated
information that we had and it was
happening truly in real time yeah I
think we're all going through that now
in real time where all of a sudden
somebody says this sport is postponed
this tournament is canceled now the
Masters is postponed and I'm starting to
wonder like what else is left what butt
is left to happen except for maybe free
agency and the NFL is pushed back and we
don't have the NFL Draft but I'm looking
at this next win this 30-day window
let's say or 45 or sick what do you
think is next
that could happen I don't I don't I
don't know and I hesitate to even wonder
I mean as far as the sports go Dan
there's dirt and there's nothing left
there's there's nothing left to to to
postpone I mean I I was just facetiming
with my wife and my kids our diet down
at the beach in Florida and our
sister-in-law said that that one of my
kids cousin said hey you can do our
little league game so maybe we'll I mean
I had a I'll just say just otama so I
was gonna be coy about it but he and I
were texting back and forth with the
players suspended actually canceled and
he's joked that he'd send in video of
his practice rounds and then by the time
we are text Shane was generally had him
and Rickie Fowler playing left-handed
with sponsors and I would wear a hazmat
suit I mean we're gonna have
come up with good content and be
creative because there's nothing left to
to postpone and I said last night on the
show that and I really do believe this
and they'd go Bear was the tipping point
because he became this this the urgency
of them suspending that game is where it
felt like a movie it's like someone's
sprinting out on the floor to say wait
you can't play and Gobert has it and
it's like it and and so the NBA almost
immediately says the season suspended
and Matt was the Domino that led
everything else to happen if he doesn't
test positive
I think right now conference tournaments
are playing with no with no fans I think
they would have continued on it was
inevitable that we're gonna run into a
stop which is some sort but in a weird
way this guy who is you know pretty
reckless and irresponsible and making
jokes about it then becomes the face of
it but then maybe can become the face in
a good way
if it turns out that you know a week
from now or whatever he's actually
healthy and you go oh so wait you mean
you don't just you know you don't just
fall over and die well I think we can
read that that's the case but when
there's a visible proof of someone
having it and you're like oh that's okay
not okay but it's not a death sentence
then it becomes an maybe a positive in
that we have a little bit more awareness
about it understanding that the elderly
those with pre-existing conditions
really have to be kept safe but the hell
knows man I mean in real time we're all
just figuring it out and it's just such
a it's just such a bummer well I also
agree with you on Rudy Gobert you know
he unintentionally
I think helped a lot of people he made
it real because you're seeing something
and once again we go back to real time
and it's like wait the Thunder jazz game
is not going to take place why and you
know the fans didn't even know as the
public address announcer says and drive
home safely and visit Oklahoma City
dot-com for more information here wait
wait what what just happened and then
Doris Burke was doing the mavs game and
she says I got like she just said I
can't focus on this I can't imagine the
pelicans Sacramento Kings game then
you're going wow like where is this
going
and if Rudy Gobert doesn't it lane the
Big East yesterday
I I go wait they're out there okay
they're gonna do
introduction wait that referee has the
boat wait they're out at the center wait
there but they're playing and I went oh
you guys and then I go oh my god at a
half-time then they cancel I went it's
just crazy
I mean I there's nothing that will ever
compare to this as far as a week and
I've been doing this for 35 years like
this is crazy you know I hope we never
have this again but it just like every
it felt like 24 hours was 48 hours yeah
it did and and again that you're the
Dominos is Gobert and the NBA because
once they said we're not doing it then
everybody else that was sort of beneath
them particularly in basketball you know
on the college side I'm like there's
just no way they can do it and I like
you I was just shocked that they that
they move forward in the garden and for
them to just to get to halftime and then
hey st. John's like yeah you're nice
half you got a lead over team it's
really good but I'm sorry that's the end
of that it was just you know and surreal
is a word that's getting the workout
right now but it certainly is that and I
know I know for a fact that a lot of
coaches in college
we're trying to convince the
n-c-double-a to postpone rather than
cancel just give some time to perhaps
allow for this to get better and improve
but the logistical challenge with venues
and with timelines for players who might
not be in college I mean so many of
these schools Dan are going online only
like you can't be on campus so where the
hell are you gonna practice and I mean
it's just it sucks for lack of a more
graceful way to put it but it's just it
really sucks for particularly for
college basketball players who are
seniors or people that were heading to
the NBA early that you know they don't
at least get 40 more minutes together to
to play because I mean that's an
incredibly abrupt thing I think of your
Dayton Flyers I said this last night I
look obviously I'm crushed for my
Maryland Terps you know what knows
that's where I'm from I'm for crushed
for date than anybody else because this
is probably as good as it'll ever be and
then it you don't even get another game
it's just it's really really horrible
Scott man pelted the mothership joining
us on the program
the Masters game plan what do you think
it is I've been talking back and forth
with a lot of people this morning and I
am I was struck by this if they did this
the man the Masters prefer the term
resources to money and I would just as
it relates as it was I mean you know
there's we don't have a back and a front
we have a first in a second night you
know all the proper terminology well the
resources at their disposal as it really
would relate to the medical community I
have to believe our are unrivaled so if
they're doing this I have to believe
that it is because they have spoken to
the leading medical authorities in the
world who just explained why now would
be a bad time I think that they are one
of the rare events in sports that could
essentially name their call their shot I
mean III know they wouldn't want to
trample you know the PGA Tour or or
obviously another major championship and
just you know play the trump card and
just name a date and say okay here's
where we're playing and it's like well
no actually we've got another event I
think they could would try to work
within the framework of is there a spot
on the schedule but truly if they said
we're playing on this date in June or
this date in September or whatever
everybody show up because it's the
Masters but I imagine that eat for all
the resources they have I don't believe
that those that they have the answer to
when this is going to pass and when
would even be feasible but my hope as
someone who loves the event is that that
they can sort out a spot on the schedule
where it makes sense but but but they
closed their course down during the
season for a period of time like it's
just closed and I don't so I don't know
I don't know when logically they'll be
able to do it I also wondered about you
know that I hate using the word but I'll
use it the optics of playing golf at the
Players Championship first round and
then all of a sudden late last night
the Commissioner says
we're not gonna we're not gonna continue
this I think they could have continued
it no fans there and I don't but I think
it would have looked bad and I think the
answer the PGA Tour was concerned about
how it looked
instead of we can actually do this and I
don't I don't know if any players are
going to have any problem with this my
guest Dan is this Rory McIlroy who is
not only the reigning champion not only
the number one player of the world but
as as thoughtful and grounded an athlete
as I think we have in sports right now
when he says you got to test everybody I
think that sends a shiver down the spine
of jmontie and the Commissioner who he
wasn't um he wasn't combative in his
press conference on Thursday but he was
explaining why they were gonna try to
play I think they were just trying to be
hopeful trying to be optimistic listen
we're gonna try to you know we're gonna
play without fans we think we could try
to protect each other this and that but
when Rory says that and then let's say
you just let's say you test the whole
field given what we were learning about
this almost certainly whether there are
symptoms being shown or not a caddie a
player somebody carrying that the sign
when the players score on it somebody
out there probably has it and then once
you find out well you know the PGA Tour
but the players at risk because
so-and-so had this virus well then and
I'm with you I don't like the term
optics but it certainly doesn't look
great if you've carried on and it turns
out that this was the circumstance you
carried on in spite of so I just think
the more they thought about it they just
so you know I like everybody's hunkering
down will join them what's the game plan
for the next week
you know Mike McQuaid
well I he was back in the day he was
your guy with Keith on the Big Show and
he's sort of my boss of bosses and we're
trying to figure it out I mean I like to
think we're a fairly creative Bunch
and we can create content in in many
different ways but I mean I'm not a I'm
not a frigging magician okay I don't
know
then I honestly don't know I don't know
what we'll do I don't know if we will
hit the pause button and just run games
like everything becomes ESPN quiet I
don't know I mean none of us has ever
have ever been confronted with
world where there truly are nothing so
games so we just desperately need to be
poppin and go nuts like you know Brady
to the Raiders you know we can make a
day out of that day I'm making a week
out of it
come on if maybe I mean you know we
could run simulations I mean but you
know we'll listen we're gonna try our
best we're gonna try to be a place
people can come for a diversion but if
we've got nothing to cover I mean I
really don't know what it's gonna look
like we were surprised how easy it was
to get a hold of you today how so we did
a guy beat hunkered down
ya know sports to coverage we figured
you were just sitting around not doing
anything all by yourself and we you know
you know we're calling Berkeley next
make sure he's okay
I mean he barely he's it making sure
he's alright I know I think I could be
in the middle of anything and I was you
know I called Bay Heim Bay Times a mess
he's at home his wife's yelling I think
we got nothing like it that's all right
that's the biggest thing right now is
like this is my favorite day this
Thursday Friday of this week and next
week my favorite days of the year and
now I've just I'm off and I I don't know
what to do
I guess I'll read a book great to talk
to you again and once again tell the
staff your guys they did a great job
this week certainly that Wednesday night
family so that was good TV means a lot
dad I appreciate you thank you buddy let
Scott Van Pelt